have you guys ever had sleep paralysis
yes one time one time yes i have
literally seen sleep paralysis demons
have you yes i have okay i've never seen
this part of me i've never yeah i've
never gotten to the demon part but i've
definitely
had because i didn't believe in sleep
paralysis until i got it
and it's so [ __ ] weird because it's
like
for those to explain what sleep
paralysis is basically you're awake but
your body's asleep yeah essentially so
your mind's awake but your body yeah so
like i believe
when you go to sleep your body like
excretes like
your mind is called a chronicle okay
your mind is a chemical that paralyzes
your body while you're sleeping i
believe
and so it's like some hunter hunter [ __ ]
yeah and and so what sleep paralysis is
is that that chemical is still in your
body so you can't like move but your
mind is still awake yeah it doesn't
sound right is that is that right ashley
can you can you can you google it
so basically uh it's basically
it's it's it's you're conscious but you
are not able to move yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i've only had it once in my life and
i thought this was nonsense before yeah
and it was like i i was it was on joey's
couch yeah really yeah what was this
just to say i mean i've never known what
that is
concrete course but a few theories all
right
demons
your sister was there your sister'd come
and i remember it was weird because they
were speaking about me and i was trying
to get up yeah say hello but i couldn't
i was face down on joey's couch
trying my best to wake up am i i was
fully aware i couldn't open my eyes but
i was fully awake and i couldn't move my
arms or legs yeah but i didn't feel that
like i was paralyzed it felt that like
even though i was like willing my body
to wake up like my arms and my legs like
my whole body wasn't listening yeah i'll
see your eyes were closed because when i
had sleep paralysis my eyes were open oh
my eyes were closed and i i could feel i
was well aware that i was awake and i
was aware of everything that was going
on around me yeah but i couldn't like it
just took a moment and i felt like there
was a battle when i was like telling
myself to wake up it like wasn't doing
it i felt like yeah like i'm pulling a
chainsaw cord you know yeah
yeah like i could feel that i was trying
to get through and it wasn't happening i
didn't understand why
i woke up for me was so [ __ ] because
like i remember i clearly just remember
opening my eyes looking around it was
like five in the morning i i saw the
clock yeah you could you could you were
looking i was your eyes were moving
around i was literally i was darting my
eyes around and i'm like why can i not
talk or hear anything or move my body
yeah oh sorry i couldn't hear anything i
couldn't hear anything either i couldn't
hear anything i i tried to like open my
mouth to say something and my mouth just
wouldn't see this is one of those things
where i feel like it's definitely the
mind like this is like a like a [ __ ]
a glitch
what the [ __ ] else do you think it is
the demons but like this is why i think
like when he's like it's a chemical i'm
like i don't know there so to me it just
sounds like a a neuron [ __ ] up in your
head that's like re like you hear that
so it's like restarting like it's like
trying to figure out so what happened
did you go back to sleep after your
sleep clearance no no no i woke up after
like 15 10 minutes yeah oh i went back
to sleep oh because this was like i'd
had a full sleep and i was waking up and
i and i woke up and i just couldn't move
my arms or legs for a little bit it
wasn't like a
it wasn't like i was trying to move in
it wasn't moving like i couldn't even
like
like figure out how to move it right
really strange i don't understand how
this worked so i remember the one time i
got sleep paralysis and i literally saw
a sleep paralysis steaming
it just looked like a ghost so what
happened is like uh so i was sleeping on
my bed
and then like i like i remember like not
waking up immediately but yeah i
remember just like opening up my eyes a
bit and seeing like this kind of like
ghostly figure i was like what the [ __ ]
is that immediate like immediately i
like punch my eyes open and like i see
like this female figure like kind of
like praying above me or something
no but it was literally like this this
uh this like looked like a nun or
something that was just like praying
like above me and i start like freaking
out because i'm just like what the [ __ ]
there is a literal ghost floating above
me right now right right how old are you
i was around 24. oh okay yeah so it was
i wasn't young i was uh yeah
around 24. and i remember i remember
like i said like i remember my mind
going into fight or flight mode just
like just like i was i started panicking
because obviously if you see like
[ __ ] ghosts floating above you you
start [ __ ] panicking so i like try to
start like moving my [ __ ] body to
like like do something and i remember my
body just would not move and it was like
i said it was [ __ ] it was a terrifying
experience right
yeah it was it was a terrifying [ __ ]
experience and i remember it took me
about like 10 minutes 10 to 15 minutes
of me like screaming at my body it's
like just like
gone move move you're gonna die you're
gonna die you're gonna die now yeah that
sounds like a dream it could it wasn't a
dream because like it felt like no
because like it
felt like a dream and not like a dream
at the same time right because he i was
obviously in my room but like after
about 10-15 minutes i actually like
finally was just like able to will my
body to like just like sit up yeah i
remember i immediately sat up i looked
up and i could see like the the figure
just like literally fading away as i sat
up
it was like super super like [ __ ]
surreal so that's that's why i'm just
like oh that was that the [ __ ] sleep
paralysis steven that everyone [ __ ]
memes about you mean that thing actually
exists what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's so weird it was like some persona
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe it was just my stance
please